[Musique]
vainqueur devant michel a commis tombe à
l'eau ce qui va arriver tout cas merci
agathe pour cette mise au point et ça me
fait bien plus mais c'est bien
valorisant web la valeur votre physique
aval à valérie blais monsieur vote utile
mois soit une aide valérie ben vous êtes
moi je trouve mignon mois d'accord il en
est mignon dire un chien isabelle morini
bosc à moi je voudrais vous trouve très
mignon mais vous n'êtes pas ma tranche
d'âge vous savez bien si je peux me
déplacer
c'est compliqué compliqué mais on a
compris les quartiers ça c'est dur alors
la plus dure c'est agamemnon mais elle
ne perdait pas confiance en vous seriez
vous plaisez à beaucoup de familles
[Applaudissements]
j'ai fait mais je suis sûr que ça plaira
quelqu'un dort et après on va dire que
c'est moi qui traumatise les
chroniqueurs vous les questions
bah oui bah alors c'est une passion
bonjour je m'appelle annick dans les
quatre lieux vous montrer tout ce qui se
passe pendant les pubs
donc je me marre parce que maintenant il
n'y a plus de pub alors lemoine dans le
cul de balayette
il remarque annick et jean voit
reconnaître que quand j'ai imaginé le
concept de la rubrique c'était plus
calme
ainsi avait plein de pub mais pas de
conducteur au l'idée à la con que j'ai
eus bon pour le départ de thierry
j'avais fait un magnéto hommage je vous
dis tout de suite je vais arrêter
1 parce qu'à ce rythme là je vais faire
plus que ça ils ont tous resigné chez
moi mais là je suis plus etc et hier
j'ai l'impression de faire la séquence
des disparus aux césars au secondaire je
vais vous dire il n'ya qu'un seul
chroniqueurs qui manquera l'émission le
jour où il décidera de partir
d'après vous je parle de questions
michel non non soyons sérieux gilbert
des noms macquinghen nom benjamin maxime
gainey c'est vraiment votre chouchou un
tout de suite dambach sinon on dit que
vous croyez que zain c'est valérie venez
non mais alors vous savez maintenant
touche pas à mon poste se découpe en
plusieurs parties il ya before l'antre 2
puis l'émission et enfin le pousse café
où je sais plus comment ça s'appelle
françois fut posée est ce que je vais
vous montrer c'est le début de
l'émission
donc la troisième partie tout est
logique certes en tant que ça chez ça
car ça veut dire qu'il est 20h10 et
qu'on est à l'antenne depuis une heure
[Applaudissements]
y à t'il vous adore non mais quand les
gens s'aperçoivent seulement au bout
d'une heure que t'es pas la droite a
posé des questions sur ton charisme sur
l'eurostar no 1 remarquez c'est étrange
mais j'ai l'impression que jean-michel
on a beaucoup plus sa présence ou
l'absence d'un gâteau proulx a ouai bon
au final je sais pas si c'est mieux
là c'était le générique de fin
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui
ah bon
un jeu à destination de voir à pau à la
veille de ce texte y voient le jour là
dessus bien le bon samaritain aller
alors vous savez jean michel est très
sensible à la beauté féminine
alors vous imaginez la semaine dernière
on recevait la magnifique gel lagardère
et qu'on reçoit une fille au physique
hors-norme toujours la question qui va
nous mettre tous bien minable
est-ce que vous avez des astuces beauté
déjà devant vous n'avez pas venez pas
besoin bon arrêté pour être toujours se
démaquiller le sort déjà ah ouais c'est
ça pour moi
les maquis et 24 heures sur 24 c'est
comme les pandas ainsi tous nos qualités
nous présenter sa bd amber blake bond
l'agent me convenait plus et ça va il
n'a pas été trop lourd la dengue qui
fait tout en humour en deux phases
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le scénario et dessin son coeur alors ça
aurait pu marcher seul problème c'est
que les dessins sont pas d'elle par
contre le scénario aussi
[Applaudissements]
je comprends pas comment il a pu
commettre une erreur pareille parce que
s'il ya bien quelqu'un qui connaît ses
dossiers
les gens me away gens mais lui c'est
simple sa devise tient en trois mots
c'est quoi tes trois mots efficacité
éthique et rigueur
non c'est même pas lui-même s'était
alors pour les jeunes qui voudraient lui
emboîter le pas tout de suite un petit
tuto boulot boulot j'ai échoué j'ai
beaucoup bossé c'est un étang j'avais
tellement bossé toute l'année
bobigny
[Musique]
d'avoir du rose
les autres critiques
[Musique]
notamment bossé toute l'année vous avez
dix ans j'ai dit quand j'ai raté une
seule annonce
le droit à un week end dans l'année où
je décompresse un passeport pour toi
exactement ils sont dix mètres et je
crois 110 m haies walid
il faut le reconnaître à la carte de
journaliste de gens mais il l'a fait
lui-même avec du papier mais
heureusement il ya des nouveaux pour
compenser comme maxime guény voilà les
hante un modèle s'est très vite intégré
en participant notamment aux nombreux
jeux inventés par le génie du paf
cyril hanouna amera je me posais une
question qui commence par pourquoi est
ce sera à vous de me donner la plus là
que tu
[Musique]
de la culture la culture que tu dixit
gilles verdez et le gagnant pouvait
désigner un chroniqueur devait se
déguisant brigitte macron c'est tombé
sur maxime et regardez comme il apprend
vite
il arrivait tous plus haut dans
l'édition plein de bons sentiments au
bout de quelques semaines dès lors
comment ils essaient de refiler la
patate chaude à ses camarades donc
désigner quelqu'un qui prétend brigitte
macro apparition très vite
[Rires]
la paloise
il a pris la bonne voie
c'est gentil ça bon au final je suis
content on a truqué d'un kim et encore
moins se déguiser que moi sauf que lui
d'ajouter une variante il se déguise pas
mais il dit qui pourrait le faire à sa
place regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la raison ils avaient raison machin
bravo et il le fera mais la nes ne
m'allait pas tout simplement c'est juste
un problème s'il est si on voit ce après
vous êtes là demain euh bah vous êtes là
mais il est qui fait des bras d'honneur
ça aurait pu sa place dans le top
gênante mais non encore une fois j'ai
trouvé des séquences plus étrange
[Musique]
chroniqueuse quelle est la question
quand nikos
[Musique]
alors moi de montrer la radio
je suis resté avec quatre cinq mois le
chef de village l'a pris et imany à la
réception le chef de village la prise et
il m'a mis à l'arrêt après on a eu des
réponses non élu aura
[Musique]
et pourquoi ça mais alors pourquoi sa
messe alors
[Musique]
elle
c'est un scandale
franchement j'en mets scénique c'est
honteux c'est remettre ça ce sont des
propos honteux
effectivement qu'il n'aurait jamais dû
passer à l'antenne parce que c'est
l'apologie du racisme à la non mais moi
j'ai pas compris
donc je dis franchement j'ai pas compris
[Musique]
c'est pas du tout intéressant de musique
et après tu fermes ta gueule à vicier va
être contente d'aller dîner avec lui a
adressé sur l'oreiller une autre
séquence qui aurait pu rentrer dans ses
complices et le vent le plus surréaliste
de l'histoire de touche pas à mon poste
à on a eu pas mal de ventre deux
personnes qui se calculait pas mais un
vent entre un chroniqueur et une
oreillette ça on n'avait jamais eu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était pas une émission
alors ce soir sur ce vide qu'est ce
qu'ils apprennent ou à ne pas manquer el
bahia est incroyable mais vrai les
records incroyable et vraie des records
elle pas mais vrai excellente émission
animée par isabelle morini bosc et
matthieu delormeau henry qui ai eu
l'idée de ce duo très bonne idée autres
elle veut dire la vérité ça fait deux
mois que j'ai ces images je vais garder
pour moi parce que c'est important
d'avoir des petits plaisirs perso on
regarde tout seul quand on a mal moral
passé vous remercie ma bravo la délation
fois suivait c'est une bonne idée alors
oubliez les grandioses la télé comme
charlie lui il dans la grille ce cas où
bob l'épongé patrick maintenant on à
isabelle et mathieu
imaginer plein de choses en préparant ma
carrière de télé pas ça tu parles radio
avec toi je suis par l'institut comme si
justin bieber avait à rêver qu'un jour
ils feraient radio écart de villa
me dépêche toi mais arrête de boire tout
le temps au tube imran tout le temps
c'est pénible un drame elle avale un peu
plus toi tu sais c'est le meilleur en
terrible du monde
les lumières quoi format visiblement tu
ne sais pas mais c'est d'ailleurs
entérite du monde de l'américain
l'émission c'est entre les prix allez on
y va
tais toi mais tu es toi
[Musique]
la chine vient ma chérie gains bien
montserrat machines viennent là mon
coeur
est mignonne calmy rey timbre on
enchaîne isabelle on dit souvent que
vous êtes une chaude chaude comme une
bouillotte c'est ça c'est les coins suis
plutôt plate comme une bouillotte pu me
permettre ça m'arrange à peut regarder
[Applaudissements]
/ ap le montage de l'émission ce soir
sont à top oui et j'aurais fait les
sites elisabeth car sur le tournage elle
a appris une chose qui aurait pu
vraiment la déstabiliser quoi ah non
mais un truc un scoop incroyable
n'aurait jamais dû la prendre mais
l'attention était trop forte
alors mathieu a lâché morceau attention
rien ne sera plus jamais comme avant
j'ai appris à son contact
dierikon j'appris donc au bras d'un trou
du cul tu vois ces cibles tout de suite
à l'essentiel
tu veux te bases d'une finance
oui j'aime pêcher se méfier de le dire
mais tu fasses des finances fille drôle
non tant pis je le dis il ya huit ans je
me suis tapé alain ce que j'aime c'est
que brady comme si c'était vrai on se
détend c'est l'humour arrive au mieux 2
sur une bonne affaire que tout seul sur
une mauvaise relance at il dit elle le
lead vocal était comestible et que ça
fait une magnifique transition pour
passer à tous qu'on n'aurait pas voulu
voir et entendre les missions et on
commence par les imitateurs de la
semaine il avait les benjamins ils ont
bien chauffé le phrasé si particulier de
maxime gainey
oui les petites anecdotes tous les toits
parce qu'on se dit comme ça taudis la
peur de rien sans des collectes à une
phobie ou pas c'est un moment et wendel
mais pas trois prénoms n'ont pas encore
battant trouvait encore
alors jeune journaliste j'avais un très
beau cv et j'avais mis une super photo
de moi en couleurs t'attaquer tôt et je
trouvais pas de boulot au dialogue photo
[Musique]
g
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est quoi le tue l'amour pour
balma un mec qui pète c'est très avec
manhattan alors bon ça passe en 81 80
comme dirait jean 19 cents
caroline ithurbide arts vous n'avez pas
une tête vous zappez caroline et mon
prénom et monde depuis toujours d'accord
les futures mines et vous auriez vous
auriez vous appelez comment je sais que
mes parents ils ont hésité entre
charlotte isabel on est livré il appelle
à l'unité quoi on espère qu'elle sera
encore longtemps isabelle en tout cas
tout le moins longtemps que je ne m'en a
jamais et on a des surprises pour
certains d'entre vous j'espère daniel
que ce soir vous allez trouver l'amour
je vais vous le dire on a lendemain
matin tout désir et il avait dit un jour
plus tôt une fois ce pas parce qu'on a
pété une fois qu'on est pétomane merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
diamant
m
en voyant ce bagne est on si ça s'est
vraiment passé je comprends pourquoi n'
aura quitté l'émission n'aura revient ça
n'arrivera plus
[Applaudissements]